he's one of our favorite guests but we
have a hard time pronouncing his name so
we don't have him on that often
steve palazzolo joining us on the
program from pro football focus how did
i do steve
it was perfect i feel like you can have
me on a little bit more now thank you
thank you stayed up all night practicing
in the mirror going
palozzolo palozzolo steve palazzolo and
i did a pro football focus
senior analyst here all right
uh let's start with sam darnold going
into tonight's game
what is the data that pro football focus
has looked at with sam darnold this year
yeah he hasn't been great he's got a
grade in the 50s which is well below
average it's
it's not good at all but i think coming
into the year i i remember saying look
if sam
sam darnold could play a lot better and
you're not even going to see it you're
not going to see it on the stat sheet
you're not going to see it in the win
loss column
and then you see last week even this not
good wide receiver core is completely
depleted
the offensive line is not great other
than the rookie makai bechten so
the situation is just so bad around sam
darnold it's not completely fair
but at the same time still way too many
bad decisions in there
in sam darnold's game and i don't think
we've really seen
the progression that you want to see
here in year three but it's tough and i
don't know how pro football focus does
this but you look at
like daniel jones i don't know if daniel
jones is good
or or just he's on a bad team or is it a
combination of both
if you look at daniel jones and sam
darnold how much is them and how much it
is
they're on a bad team yeah i mean
jones's grade is a
is what jets fans would be hoping for
from donald jones is up in the 70s he's
actually grading really well despite
everything around him despite facing
more pressure dropbacks than any other
quarterback in
a terrible offensive line and again not
the greatest group of playmakers so yeah
there is a way and the way we do it is
to try to
isolate the quarterbacks play as much as
possible so you make a great throw
whether it's caught or dropped we're
still giving you credit for that throw
you still have to make good decisions
you still have to throw the ball
accurately
even if you don't have that many guys
that are open so
there are ways to kind of parse out the
quarterback play from
the rest of the supporting cast but as
we've seen would say like josh allen
in buffalo when you have everything
around you getting better every single
year it certainly
helps your development that's why i
think alan's really peaking here in year
three
best rated quarterback by pro football
focus this year is who
it's aaron rodgers yeah he's just been
in a whole different world and him and
russell wilson are really in a in a
different world
we went back to 2006 and said okay
through three weeks
what are the highest grades we've ever
seen rogers is number three wilson's
number five so it's two of the better
performances we've seen
through three weeks they're going
they're neck and neck rod wilson's got
better stats i think he's
had a little bit more favorable you know
screens for touchdowns and wide open
drag routes for touchdown so his stats
are a little bit better than rogers but
roger's throw for throw
he's been the best quarterback in the
league but there was so much angst
concern about aaron rodgers coming into
this season and you didn't draft a wide
receiver you drafted another running
back you drafted a fullback here
does rogers buy in with the game plan
with matt leflore
and now what's happened the last part
he's bought in i mean
the biggest thing with aaron rodgers
right the last few years if you put up
his highlight reel
against anyone else's it's right there
his big time throws special does he turn
the ball over no he's got these
the extreme ends of the spectrum have
been awesome for rogers his entire
career
it's that middle bit where in 2011 and
14 and stretches of 16
he was awesome but in recent years he
lost it a little bit he didn't trust the
system he wasn't getting the ball out on
time he was trying to play
hero ball outside of structure too much
this year he's getting rid of the ball
faster 2.5 seconds
in the pocket when he's usually up
around 2.9 or 3. that is a
massive difference that is trust that is
the scheme
and it's not with the best group of
receivers either it's devante adams was
hurt the other day
rogers is still making these guys look
good he is playing at a special level
because he's
trusting matt lafleur the system and
hitting open receivers
but why is it that tom brady didn't have
weapons
but cam newton has weapons in new
england
i don't know that cam really does i mean
i think in the seattle game we saw
uh that was a really nice job of them
opening up the passing attack they used
julian edelman a little bit more down
the field exploited a mismatch with
jamal adams
i still think it's to be seen you know
brady was really good through three
weeks last year as well
i think the passing game in new england
still is not one of the better ones in
the league
it is edelman and a whole bunch of
question marks with nikhil harry and
damir byrd so
i think there's still a little bit more
to see about what new england can do
through the passing attack
i think they've done a nice job with the
run game and building around cam but i
still don't think they have great
weapons or
an explosive passing attack that is
feared around the nfl
how have you graded dak prescott really
high he's
uh seventh i believe in our overall
grades he's great and extremely well
he's
you know he reminds me of patrick
mahomes right now the way mahomes was in
at texas tech where there's just no
margin for error you know
you've got 39 points against the falcons
you know you're in a shootout
against the seattle seahawks so dak is
playing well throw for throw he's
excellent but
there's an interception here a fumble
there that just there's just no margin
for error there because they're like
it's like they're playing big 12 games
but
dax doing a really good job of throwing
the ball accurately beyond the sticks
throwing the ball down the field
and yeah top 10 quarterbacks so far does
it make sense to give that
running back that second contract that
we saw with alvin kamara
um you know christian mccaffrey got it
dalvin cook got it because i've been a
big proponent of i
i'm gonna ride you for five years and
i'm gonna say goodbye to you where does
pro football focus stand on that
yeah we completely agree we would never
give a second contract
and you always kind of get fooled who's
the special one is it todd gurley is he
special
well no and in part of the reason you
know mccaffrey could have boxed the
trend because we're all about the pass
game at pff because that's what's
more efficient so even when you have a
pass catching running back
it's still not great i think the
panthers offense could be a little bit
better without mccaffrey
because they don't feel the need to give
him touches and they have guys like
robbie anderson and dj moore if they get
more uh attempt at targets down the
field that offense will be better so
i love christian mccaffrey i love dalvin
cook i think he's fantastic
but i would never get into that second
contract situation one because
of the injury situation and then two
because the production just
never matches the dollar amount for a
running back i was shocked of all the
games over the weekend
even detroit winning in arizona i was
not shocked by that
but carolina beating the chargers
what the hell is going on i know that
everybody's got injuries
but justin herbert has played well i
think
how does pro football focus see the
chargers yeah they're they're a little
confusing because a week before
it was like man they're they're giving
the chiefs all that they can handle into
overtime especially defensively the fact
that mahomes
you know only had that one really big
play the previous week i think the
chargers offensive line they've been a
disaster for years
and we saw a panthers team that only had
nine pressures through two games and
they are getting pressure brian burns
with a strip sack and they're actually
beating this chargers offensive line i
think that is one of those things that
will hurt herbert's development just a
little bit he's got some good dudes to
throw to obviously but
the old line has to get better and i
think that's what really did them in
last week even against a bad panthers
pass rush
steve palozzolo pro football focus
senior analyst by the way use the promo
code radio 25 you get 25
off a pro football focus subscription at
pff.com
who do you guys like tonight oh man
i mean i guess i guess the broncos um
you know i think it's it's not a great
game on paper i mean
the darnold should be the he should have
the advantage
from a quarterback uh you know situation
brett ripon did some nice things in his
little relief outing
against the tampa bay bucks last week
but both teams are in a rough spot my
biggest concern with the jets is they're
just
bad at the most important spots right so
pass game wide receiver
cornerback it was that was their issue
coming into the year it's their issue
right now
denver can at least play reasonably on
the back end
um so i think they've they've got a shot
you know in this one
when you look at drew brees's
performance so far
is there anything different through the
first three weeks that we
should have seen coming late last year
yeah so i mean if you look at breeze's
last six games just by pff grades that's
almost they're almost all of them are
between
58 and 62 all six of them right in that
range and
that's well below average it's not good
and he said some games in there that
were pretty good statistically but the
difference in those games is the
downfield passing attack
throwing an interception against
minnesota down the field in the playoffs
last year that
carried over into this year he is just
not
making those throws down the field he's
not attempting him he only has three
attempts beyond 20 yards
one for three on those passes and one
was a busted coverage the one completion
so
it's a completely different saints
offense he's always thrown short he's
always
let his playmakers do work but if you
leave the seam open he's going to zip it
in there if you leave a deep ball open
he's going to hit it
that is the difference with the saints
offense so they're just it's a really
tight margin of error you obviously
can't
rely on alvin kamara to take a you know
a negative five yard pass and turn it
into a 52 yard touchdown every single
week
like he's been so um that's the issue
right now brees
not being aggressive down the field and
when he is the arm is just not there and
the accuracy
that we've normally you know been
accustomed to i saw an article on pro
football focus about the possibility of
the falcons trading
matt ryan uh you know in theory it
sounds interesting that now you're going
to tank for trevor but
who would take matt ryan right now and
what are you getting for matt ryan
are you just trying to get him off the
books and then
you just continue to tank for trevor
lawrence yeah it's a
it's a fascinating thing that i don't
think will actually happen i remember
you know we were talking about it
internally you know what if let's just
throw this out there and see it's
it's obviously uncommon you know before
nick foles took over last week you'd say
would the bears be one of those teams
they're sitting there at 3-0 and
you know matt ryan has always been a
top-tier quarterback top 10 type of
quarterback his entire career
i think in atlanta there's just
something off they should have this
baseline
of success just having matt ryan and
julio jones and calvin ridley like they
should be winning
you should be able to slot them in for
seven or eight games just to start the
season
and then okay let's see how well the
defense plays but something's off down
there and it would be fascinating to see
do you just completely blow it up and
we're at this point in the nfl though
it's it's tough to find a spot for matt
ryan
yeah because i think there's about 28 29
30
legit starting quarterbacks around the
nfl i don't think we've seen that in
in many many years i don't think there's
a ton of massive quarterback holes
around the nfl so it'd be tough to find
an actual spot for him but from an
atlanta standpoint
would be interesting to see if they
would completely start from scratch has
pro football focus
examined trevor lawrence yeah i mean we
grade every single play from him in
college and he was the highest graded
true freshman
that we've ever had last year as a
sophomore he started out a little bit
slow but
you know if you if you do like a little
cut off of week three or four
another great outstanding play and we've
got every single one of his plays graded
this year
unbelievable accuracy to all levels of
the field i know it's against the
citadel and against lesser teams but
he's looking really good and i think you
know he's got everything you're looking
for as far as a
downfield playmaker uh short area
accuracy decision making
as a true freshman he only had three
turnover worthy plays we've never seen
anything like that that's used true
freshman is supposed to make mistakes he
didn't
plus he's got a little bit of
athleticism right so he could pick up
yards on the ground so
i think when people hype them up as the
next andrew luck type of prospect i
think it's all pretty legit
who's the quarterback we should be
talking about in college
well look i i've got i've got some gator
ties through my ears i love danny
warfield growing up
and the grade wasn't great on kyle trask
coming in he had some blind spots for
linebackers last year but if you take
away those bad plays
you could see the talent and trask did
not play
in high school he is a late bloomer with
nfl type ability accuracy and velocity
and we saw that against ole miss last
week so kyle trask i think
he's not going to put up joe barrow
numbers this year despite his start but
he'll be that guy that kind of breaks
out the nfl is going to love him he just
has to lose that blind spot for
linebackers that he
still kind of has but i love kyle trask
in his development yeah but if we take
out the bad plays from mitchell trubisky
he still has a job
he still has more bad plays than
everyone else
it was a handful for trask last year
well yeah but is trubisky worse than
carson wentz this year
not this year carson wentz is at a
special level of bad right now
it's just not good i mean he looks like
a pitcher that has the yips
just it there's something mental going
on there so 2015
if you remember andrew luck the start to
his season it looked nothing like
the first three years of andrew luck's
career nothing like it at all he was
interceptions fumbles accuracy was all
over the place it made zero sense
and people thought he was playing with
injury and then he eventually got hurt
and missed a bunch of that season
that's what wentz feels like you know
this is nothing like the rest of his
career he is our lowest graded
quarterback he's lowest in accuracy
he's got 12 turnover worthy plays no one
else has more than six like everything
is at the worst
spot that it could possibly be in so i'm
expecting it to get better
and it just it doesn't make sense
because it's not in line with the rest
of wence's career so i guess
i'm chalking it up to this is just a
massive slump that he has the talent to
come out of
great to talk to you again steve and now
that i've worked on pronouncing your
name we'll uh
try to have you back on again thank you
perfect i'll see you next week
okay i'll see you tomorrow steve
balazolo pro football focus senior
analyst
use the promo code radio 25 for 25
percent off
a pro football focus subscription at
pff.com